[MUSICAL SOUND EFFECT]
STEPHANIE WONG: Hey,
everyone, and welcome
to the third episode
of #AskGoogleCloud.
It's a show where we answer the
most pressing question facing
humanity--
is it GIF or is it JIF?
OK, actually, on
second thought, it's
probably better
that we don't start
a war in the comment section.
So let's just stick
with Cloud topics.
I'm Stephanie Wong, a
Cloud developer advocate.
And today I am joined by fellow
developer advocates Seth Vargo
and Carter Morgan.
Today we are answering
questions submitted
by you, our fantastic Google
Cloud YouTube and social media
audience.
Post your questions in the
comments with #AskGoogleCloud,
and they might be featured
on a future episode.
And if you have other
questions that come up
as you're watching
today, please go ahead
and type them in the live
chat, and we'll do our best
to try and get to all of them.
We are going to be hosting
#AskGoogleCloud segments
throughout the year, so be sure
to subscribe to the channel
to get notified every time
a new episode comes out.
All right.
So with that said,
let's get started
with today's topic, security.
All right.
So our first question
of the day comes
from Krishnadev M., who asks,
does two-factor authentication
fully protect us?
So Seth, we'll start
with you for this one.
I know you have a lot of
background in this area.
SETH VARGO: Awesome.
Thanks, Stephanie, and thanks,
Krishnadev, for the question.
So what you have to think about
when you think about MFA, which
is multifactor
authentication, or 2FA,
which is two-factor
authentication,
is defense in depth.
We know that a username is
kind of public information.
A password is something private.
And then multifactor
auth or two-factor auth
is something else
that an attacker
would need to
compromise in order
to gain access to your account.
If you ever see a question
like, is something 100% secure,
or does this fully protect
us, the answer is always no.
Nothing is 100% secure.
Nothing is 100% preventative.
But it's all about
defense in depth.
We like to talk about
layers of an onion
when we talk about security.
But I actually like
to talk about security
in terms of medieval times.
See, the thing is,
we didn't really
invent defense in depth in
the computer security space.
If you think about a
castle, most people
are familiar with a moat, right?
You surround the castle with
a moat and a drawbridge,
and you put scary
alligators in the moat.
And then people have to cross
that moat to get to the castle.
But if that's all an
attacker had to do,
they could just swim
really fast and go
get the prince, princess,
king, queen, whatever.
Actually, if we look at the
way that castles were designed
and architected
during medieval times,
they practiced defense in depth.
It wasn't just a moat, but
the actual architecture
of the castle was designed
such that the prince, princess,
king, queen were
maximally protected.
Just as an example, the
stairways in medieval castles
were designed such
that they would
curve up and to the right.
And this was primarily
so that the defender,
the people defending the
castle, had an advantage.
They had a height advantage
since they would be coming down
the stairs, and
since most people
were predominantly
right-handed during that era,
they had a swing advantage.
They were swinging at a downward
angle, gravity giving them
favor, and with
their dominant hand.
When you compare this
to the attacker, who
is swinging at a back swing,
up a hill, on an incline,
they have a disadvantage.
So this idea of defense in depth
is really not a new concept.
It's existed for hundreds
of thousands of years.
We're just applying it.
So nothing is 100% secure.
But that doesn't mean you
still shouldn't do it.
You should definitely adopt
multifactor authentication
or two-factor authentication
if your upstream account
provider supports it.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
I'm surprised we don't
have curved stairways
in our data centers, at
least not that I've seen.
But maybe we will.
But it's cool how we
translate those concepts
into our logical security, too.
And one way that I know our
security specialists here
think of it is to explain
2FA as something you know
and something you have, right?
So something you know, like
the password or the PIN number,
and then something you have,
like your phone, token,
or other digital device.
And then the other
thing is something
you are, so something unique
to your physical being,
like biometrics, or
fingerprints, palm prints,
retina scans, GPS location.
I know that I went through that
at the data center, which we'll
talk about in a little bit.
But yeah, it's all an
extra layer of protection,
like you said.
All right.
So moving on to our
second question--
so we have a question from
Alessandro C., who asks,
how can we secure a Google
Cloud Storage bucket, in which
we store sensitive client CSVs?
Are there any best
practices to consider?
So Seth, can you go ahead and
answer this one for us, too?
SETH VARGO: Yeah.
This is also a
great question that
really leads into a discussion
around threat modeling.
What are you trying
to protect against?
What are the attack
vectors that you're
trying to protect against?
In case of Google Cloud
Storage, you can enforce ACLs,
or "ack-els," access
control lists,
on individual objects within
a Cloud Storage bucket.
And you can govern those with
identity and access management,
or IAM.
So you can ensure
that only customer
A has access to object
A and customer B only
has access to CSB B.
Now, you could also
add additional controls
on top of that, on top of
identity and access management,
such as VPC Service Controls,
where you can define a service
perimeter around a Cloud Storage
bucket or other Google Cloud
resources so that they're
not accessible outside
of authorized networks or
outside of other projects
that you've pre-configured.
So really, there is
no checklist box,
and your Cloud Storage bucket
is now magically secure.
You need to think about your
threat model, what you're
protecting against, what
are the access patterns,
and how can you most restrict
those resources to only
be accessed by
the customers when
they need to access it from
where they need to access it.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
I think VPC Service
Controls are great.
As you said, you define
fine-grained perimeter controls
that enforce your security
posture across your Google
Cloud Services.
I've used it with BigQuery
and Cloud Storage.
And it helps, really,
with data exfiltration.
And then I think you
might have talked
a little bit about
context-aware access as well.
Is that similar to
identity-aware proxy?
SETH VARGO: So it's a
little bit different.
So context-aware access is like,
given my current context, which
could be like my device,
my mobile phone, my laptop,
or perhaps my
location, my network,
do I have permission to
access this resource?
So even though I am Seth,
can Seth access this resource
in this context, right?
Maybe I can only access it when
I'm at home on my home network,
but I can't access
it if I'm at a hotel
on an untrusted network.
Identity-aware proxy is
a Google Cloud product
that you can put in front
of one of your applications
and resources that let you
enforce these types of policies
so that you don't have
to modify your code.
So it sits in
front of your code.
So you can apply
these policies so you
don't have to modify your
own code in order to enforce
some of these policies.
So they're related,
but slightly different.
STEPHANIE WONG: Got it, got it.
So identity-aware proxy in
front of your sensitive app,
it's like if you want to
grant access to all employees
if they're from a trusted
corporate device versus
granting access to employees in
like a privileged access group
if the URL path starts
with something like /admin.
OK, so moving on to
question number three--
the next question is
from Dilipxs, who asks,
how do you check if
there are any security
breaches in the Cloud?
Carter, let's go to
you for this one.
CARTER MORGAN: Thank you,
Stephanie and Dilipxs.
Really, this comes down to
two things, in my opinion,
one which I'm
assuming is kind of
taken care of-- but maybe
you shouldn't assume--
but having policies
in place to say
who should be able to
access what and when.
And Seth was kind of
touching on that before when
he said there's
context, and there's
things like IAM to
say which roles can
access this safely and fine.
So if you've set that up,
that's the first step.
Because then you can do
things like have logging
set up to say, what people
accessed accounts when,
at what time?
And then you can start
to make decisions
based on these activities.
So if people are
accessing information
at a really, really late
point in time, you might say,
that's suspicious.
Let's look into this more.
But that again starts with
having some policies set up
in place to say who should
be able to access what, when.
Yeah, and then I think another
thing that's really useful
is having, basically, a
hub where you can find
this information pretty easily.
And so these are things
Google Cloud kind of
provides that I like.
But I think those are the
first steps to finding out
about security breaches.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
And I think one of those hubs,
for example, is our Security
Command Center, right?
And I have seen it evolve
over the past few years,
and they've done a really great
job at designing dashboards
like Security Health Analytics,
where you can see at a glance
the number of projects you have,
what resources are deployed,
and then manage which
service accounts have
been added or removed.
And then it actually even gives
you actionable recommendations
when it surfaces any
misconfigurations or compliance
violations, and has some
more advanced features, too,
like detecting threats for
common container attacks.
And we actually have a series.
So I'm going to plug that
here, because I worked on it.
But it's called "Getting Started
with Security Command Center."
So go ahead and check that out.
It's in our YouTube channel.
So thank you, Carter.
We're going to move on
to our next question.
And it's from
Dheeraj P., who asks,
are service accounts in some
way related to access scopes?
So Carter, do you have
any thoughts on this?
CARTER MORGAN: I
have some thoughts.
I actually want to know more
about what access scopes are,
because off the top of my head,
I don't know what that is.
I might have to defer.
But when I think about
service accounts,
the first thing I think
about is automated access.
So instead of having a person
manually log in to everything,
what if I have an application
or a script that can log in
and run things, update
something for me?
And then when I think about
that, that automation,
it's like, well,
how do I do this
in a way that's safe or secure?
I don't want to have to
take my personal password
and just write it down somewhere
that a script can look at,
because then it's very unsafe.
And so service
accounts solve that.
But when it comes into
the access scopes,
I'm actually like, if Stephanie
or Seth have more context
there, I would love to hear it.
Because I want to
know about that, too.
SETH VARGO: Yeah, I can
definitely chime in.
So you have to kind of
forget about Google Cloud
for a second, because
access scopes actually
come from OAuth, which
is the authentication
mechanism by which you
authenticate to Google Cloud.
But it's an open
standard, and it's also
how you kind of like
sign in with GitHub,
sign in with Twitter, et cetera.
And OAuth, the standard,
defines access scopes
as the access control.
So for example, let's say
you're giving someone access
to your Twitter account.
When you do that, you're
authorizing actions
that they can take
on your behalf.
So you may grant someone
read-only access.
They can only read your tweets
and your direct messages.
But you could also
grant them the ability
to tweet on your behalf.
You might do this
when you sign in
with a tweet bot or some
third-party application.
Those permissions
actually map to what
we call OAuth scopes, which we
call access scopes on Google
Cloud.
So when Google Cloud was
first getting created, or even
before Google Cloud, when there
were just Google Developer
APIs, we relied on access
scopes as basically identity
and access management.
So in order to
control whether or not
you had permission to
read from a Cloud Storage
bucket versus writing to
a Cloud Storage bucket,
you had different access scopes.
But there are some limitations
on the specification.
I won't go into a lot of detail.
But we've since evolved
Google Cloud platform
to have a really, really
rigorous identity and access
management system.
So in general, when you're
interacting with Google Cloud,
we recommend that you grant
the Cloud platform OAuth scope
to the account that's
being authorized,
and then you leverage
identity and access management
to give really fine-grained
roles and permissions that
follow the principle
of least privilege.
STEPHANIE WONG: Got it, got it.
And if I recall
correctly, I think
there might be a case where if
you're using a default service
account, it still has
access scopes without IAM.
Is that true?
SETH VARGO: Yeah.
So if you're running on Google
Compute Engine or Google
Kubernetes Engine, there is
a default service account
that has some pretty
restrictive access scopes.
So when you actually provision a
virtual machine or a Kubernetes
cluster, you get
to pick-- do you
want access to all Cloud
APIs, the default APIs,
or none, which is no scopes?
And in general,
you should probably
click the box that
says all APIs,
and then use identity and
access management instead
to practice the principle
of least privilege.
But for backwards
compatibility reasons,
or for workloads that have
existed for 10 or 20 years,
we preserve the default
behavior for the default service
account, which does use
those restricted access
scopes as a way to do ACLs.
STEPHANIE WONG: Makes sense.
OK.
So moving on to our
next question, and this
is from Guillaume
B., who asks, when
should I use a service
account key file?
Or when can I avoid it?
On prem, locally, on GCP?
So Seth, can you
answer this one for us?
SETH VARGO: Yeah.
This is a really funny
question, because Guillame and I
have actually talked about
this offline at length.
Real quick, I do
want to clarify,
what Guillame is asking
is about a service account
key, which is different
than a service account.
So Carter already gave a
really good explanation
of a service account.
It's basically a robot that
can authenticate like a human.
As a human, you
tend to authenticate
with like a password.
Well, a service account
doesn't have a password.
It's usually just
an email address.
So the way that you--
I'll use air quotes-- "log
in" as a service account is
with the service account key.
It's basically the password.
And anyone who has that key
can authenticate and act
as that service account.
So to directly
answer the question,
when should I use the
service account key,
the answer is never.
You should use
service account keys
as infrequently as possible,
because you convert an identity
management problem into a
secrets management problem.
Where are you going
to put the key?
How are you going to rotate it?
How are you going to
audit access to it?
What happens if it gets in the
hands of an unauthorized party?
So in general, you should
use service accounts
or service account impersonation
as much as possible.
So let's say you're
working locally,
whether you're
building an application
or you're running
something like Terraform.
You should authenticate with
gcloud or the Cloud SDK.
When you do this, your
local human authentication
credentials will automatically
be picked up by those tools.
Similarly, if you're using
any client library that Google
Cloud publishes
or any SDK, we'll
automatically use what are
called default application
credentials to pull
the credentials
from your local machine.
If you're running
on Google Cloud,
Cloud Run, GCE,
Kubernetes, whatever,
you can use the machine identity
or the workload identity
to attach a service account
specifically to the workload.
So for Cloud Run
or GCE, you pick
which service account you
want to use when you spin up
the service or the VM.
For, say, Kubernetes,
you actually
use workload identity to map
the Kubernetes service account
to a GCP service account.
In all of these
situations, you're
still using service accounts,
but there's no key exchange.
We're relying on Google
Cloud to provide the identity
to the service--
specifically, the
metadata service, if you
want to get into some detail.
But then you might ask yourself,
well, what if I multi-cloud?
What if I'm running on
another cloud provider?
How do I authenticate that?
Well, if you're running
on, say, AWS or Azure,
you can use workload
identity federation-- or WIF,
as I like to call it-- to
basically delegate trust.
You can use information from,
say, that other cloud provider,
and present that as an
attestation to Google Cloud.
And assuming that
you've configured
it to allow that attestation,
you can exchange,
say, your AWS credential
for a GCP credential--
again, never actually exporting
a JSON service account key.
So that really leaves
the on-premise scenario,
where you don't have an identity
provider like Active Directory,
or you have some collection
of disparate systems.
This is really
the only situation
in which you would need to
export a service account key,
where you don't have
what we call an IDP
or an identity provider
that is OIDC-compliant.
In those situations,
unfortunately,
today, the only option is to
export a service account key.
But in general,
especially working locally
on your laptop or anything
that you run on Google Cloud,
you should be able to do
so without exporting a JSON
service account key.
And in fact, if you work
for a large enterprise,
your company might have
an organization policy
that prevents you from
downloading those service
account keys, which we
can talk about more maybe
in a future episode
on org policies,
because that's at least
a 30-minute episode
all on its own.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
This can branch out all
sorts of directions.
But to sum it up, as you
said, so best practices
is use attached service
accounts whenever possible,
or workload identity to attach
service accounts to Kubernetes
pods.
Or you said WIF, workload
identity federation,
to let applications running
on-premise or other clouds
to use a service account,
and using service account
keys if there's no
viable alternative,
so only when it's sort of
the last possible scenario.
All right.
So let's go ahead and move
on to the next question.
And this is from
Ettan2007, who asks,
how do you guard against
one or more rogue employees?
And this is talking about at
one of Google's data centers.
So Carter, let's go to you
for this tough question.
CARTER MORGAN: For
this tough one--
if there's a gaggle of rogue
Googlers, what do we do?
Thank you, Ettan2007,
for this one.
There's really a lot
of different ways
that this happens.
Seth and Stephanie
already talked about this,
but Google has this thing
called defense in depth.
There's a lot of different
measures in place.
So some of those
measures are limiting
who has access to what.
So example-- and
I think I saw this
in Stephanie's
amazing data center
video, which, if you haven't
checked it out, go see it.
It's amazing.
But less than 1% of Googlers
have access to the data center.
So I don't know where
the data centers are.
I couldn't go log
in to one right now.
So that takes me
out of the picture.
Two, there's a lot of
training and policies on who
can access what and when, like
when is it OK to access data?
And so we get a lot
of training on that.
And then Stephanie
mentioned earlier about
how you can pair something
you have with something
you know with something you are.
And these are examples
of defense in depth.
And this applies to
the data center, too.
So there's scanners to
say, hmm, who are you?
Should you be here?
And if you shouldn't,
you can't, supposedly,
get access to what's
inside the data center.
So there's a lot
of different ways
and a lot of different
defense measures
that Google has in place to
protect the data centers.
And I think Stephanie can
go into a lot more detail
here, because you made this
amazing video about all
of this.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
Well, actually, Seth, do
you want to cover it first?
SETH VARGO: Yeah.
So I'll let you talk
about the data centers,
since you're far more
knowledgeable there.
I'll talk a little
bit about, maybe,
Google's internal
controls that we have.
So one of the things that
you always worry about
is like one employee
going off and downloading
a whole bunch of data
or looking at things
that they shouldn't look at.
And internally at
Google, we have a number
of controls and
systems in place that
enforce kind of three things.
They enforce your
authentication,
so are you who you say you are?
We already talked around
context-aware access.
We have custom-built
hardware for doing
multifactor authentication
using security keys.
So let's just say that's
kind of a solved problem.
Then we have, do you have
cause for accessing this data?
So Googlers can't
just go look at data.
There needs to be
probable cause, kind
of like in a courtroom, almost.
That cause could be a
customer support ticket.
It could be a production outage.
There's a number of safeguards,
maybe like 20 of them.
But whenever I'm trying
to access user data,
or any Googler is trying
they have to provide
some justification.
And that justification,
again, can come
from a number of other sources.
It could be customer-initiated,
or it could be from an outage.
And then the third
piece of information
they have to provide
or go through
is usually some
multi-party approval.
So even if there's a
support case, in order
to go look at the
user data, they
would need someone else on their
team or their sister SRE team
to approve that request.
That request is time-limited.
They may only have that
authorization for, say,
30 minutes or an
hour until they need
to renew that authorization.
So multi-party approvals
and justifications, and then
an underlying audit log
that tracks all of this.
So even if someone goes
through all the processes
and approvals, there's
still an audit log
under the hood that demonstrates
the steps they took,
who approved it, what tickets
or tickets was it attached to.
And then ultimately,
that can get
surfaced in our access
transparency report, which
is a Google Cloud product, where
you can see if a Googler has
accessed your data,
why they accessed it,
and what approvals they
went through to do so.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
It's all about reducing insider
risk through automation,
doing things in a very
safe and controlled way
with the two-party approvals
and the limited APIs
so that we don't expose
any sensitive information.
But yeah, same thing goes
for Google employees' access
to any end-user information
through access transparency,
as you mentioned.
So there's a
security white paper
that you all should check out.
Lots of stuff that Seth
has worked on as well.
But to just touch on the data
center experience that I have,
I can tell you from experience
it was very difficult
for me to even be able to be
in there in the first place.
But ACLs are
important, so you have
to be on an access control list
to even be authorized to enter.
There is, as I said, the
badge readers everywhere.
There is biometric scanning at
certain locations in the data
center in particular, especially
the data center floor.
So lots of measures in place
to prevent rogue employees
as well as anyone
trying to leave the data
center by bringing anything out.
There is metal detectors as you
leave certain areas as well.
So--
SETH VARGO: And if I could
just chime in real fast.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
SETH VARGO: We don't just do
those things for insider risk,
as well.
So I know it sounds a
little Big-Brothery,
but I wanted to add an
additional color on why
this infrastructure exists.
And we'll probably get to
this a little bit later.
But if there was ever, say,
a fire at a data center,
it's really important that
Google's global security team
knows who is in
that data center so
that we can ensure that
everyone was evacuated safely.
The same goes for, say,
a physical building.
If there was a natural
disaster, like an earthquake,
we need to make sure that
all of those Googlers
are safe and accounted for.
So it's not purely about
preventing insider risk.
That's obviously
one of the benefits.
But this data
exists for a number
of internal systems,
a lot of which
are designed to help
keep Googlers safe.
STEPHANIE WONG: Absolutely.
That's important to
underline as well.
And I'll talk a little bit more
about that in just a moment.
But we do have a
related question.
And this is from
David Adams, who asks,
I wonder if all data centers
have the identical six
layers of security, or if this
is just your flagship data
center?
This is probably a
question from the video
that I had created
about the six layers.
And this is related
to, also, the concept
of defense in depth.
So I'm going to go ahead and
actually answer this one.
But yes, all of
our data centers do
have and follow the same
layered approach of security
at this time.
So if you watch the video,
which you can check out
at bit.ly/6layersdeep, you'll
learn that layers become
progressively more protected
with access checks as you move
to the core of the data center.
So you have layer 1, which
is the exterior, the security
perimeter, the
property boundaries.
And then layer 2 is
the main entrance gate.
So that has a vehicle
crash barrier,
fences with motion detection,
guard kiosks, thermal cameras.
Layer 3 is building access,
with the general office
area where our hardware
and operations team work.
It actually looks just
like a regular Google
office in this section, too.
But it also includes an
isolated loading dock area
where secure shipments
are made from vendors
that we have already approved.
Layer 4, inside the
data center itself.
It includes operational
rooms like the core network
room and the security
operation center.
Now, this is very related to
what Seth was just mentioning.
The SOC contains a
highly trained staff
that monitors all
aspects of security.
And they're responsible
for keeping a level
head at all times--
for example, during
these major events,
or if there's a natural
disaster-- to keep people safe.
Layer 5 is the
data center floor.
And that includes
multifactor authentication
like badge readers,
biometric scans, et cetera.
It's the most protected area.
And it also includes
layer 6, which is inside.
And that's disk arrays.
So once again, go
ahead and check out
the video to get a
full experience of what
it was like to go through that.
All right, so moving
on-- our next question
is actually a question
we have received
from a lot of our viewers of
our security content on YouTube.
And that is, why does Google
destroy hard drives at its data
centers instead of
overwriting them?
Now, I just talked about disk
arrays, which is layer 6.
But let's start
with you, Carter,
for this popular question.
CARTER MORGAN: Oh, I love it,
because this is a question I've
seen even on series I've made.
And I think, to
answer this, I want
to first touch back to
some of the things we've
talked about here.
Google is constantly
taking multiple steps
to secure our data.
And this is the
same kind of thing.
So if someone were to take a
drive, that data is encrypted.
Sometimes it's
hardware-encrypted,
where there is specific
chips on a device
to encrypt and decrypt it.
But if someone were to
actually have a physical drive,
they have something-- they
have an advantage, a very large
advantage, and that's time.
And so they can
brute-force, and they
might be able to figure
out ways to access that.
So destroying that
is another step
to prevent things like that.
And then something
I hadn't realized--
when I was talking
with Seth before this,
we were running through some
of the questions and whatnot.
And he was like,
yeah, well, have
you thought about
future technology,
and how future technology
might be able to do things
that we can't right now?
And so this is another way
to prevent against that.
Sure, the encryptions
might be very safe now,
with today's technology,
but what about in 20 years?
And so this is just another step
for ensuring that our data is
safe and secure on Google.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
Seth, do you have
anything to add there?
SETH VARGO: Yeah.
I'll just draw a quick
analogy, because Carter kind of
explained it eloquently.
But people love to use the
word post-quantum crypto,
so I won't go there.
What I will say is let's
talk about DNA, right?
DNA is an important part
of every criminal case
that you see today.
But 20 years ago, no
one talked about DNA.
It was all fingerprint--
loops and hooks.
And fingerprint evidence
is still important,
but we've made pretty
significant advancements
in the biomedical space
with respect to DNA
and how we can use
DNA in criminal cases.
You can imagine that something
similar will probably
happen in 20 years with
respect to data recovery.
And that's really
one of the reasons
why we're investing so
heavily in this space
and why we do truly shred,
physically, these hard drives--
because we don't want
to be in a situation
where someone grabs one
of these hard drives,
puts it on a shelf for 20
years, and then there's
this magical new scanner
that you put over it
and it extracts all of the
data as if it was in plaintext.
And physically destroying
the drives is really, again,
part of defense in depth.
It's one of the ways that
we can truly prevent that
from happening, no matter what
advancements in technologies
might exist in the future.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
I think it's also
important to note
that we do try to recycle
drives and their components.
But in the case that a
drive cannot be erased,
then it is stored securely until
it can be physically destroyed.
And if you're wondering
what happens to this waste,
we do have researchers
in our Oklahoma facility
who are looking into methods
of collecting and recycling
these rare earth
metals in hard drives.
As you might know, data centers
are the largest consumers
of these hard
drives that contain
these elements like dysprosium,
and so these elements
have a major role in components
of things like electric cars
and wind turbines.
And so we're doing a lot there
to make better use of them.
And there's a great
article to check out
if you want to learn
more about that.
All right.
So our next question comes
from Oliver M., who asks,
why is there so much
physical security
at Google data centers?
And is there any
reason to believe
that people might
want to destroy
the data or the servers?
So Seth, I'm going to
throw this one at you.
SETH VARGO: Yeah, so
this is a great one.
It's kind of a
two-part question.
So Carter already
answered the first part,
which is once you
have physical access
to a device or a machine or a
hard drive, a lot of the bets
are off, right?
If I can run a scan
on those hard drive,
if I can try to brute-force
the various decryption keys,
if I can plug a thumb drive
in, I can do a lot more damage.
To draw an analogy, not
thinking about the data center,
if I have a Wi-Fi access
point in my building,
I can't do much with
that access point
if it's up on the ceiling.
But if I can get
it down on my desk,
I can stick a paperclip
into the Reset button.
And I can reset it,
I can provision it
with my own custom firmware,
I can directly connect to it.
The threat model changes.
The threat model becomes
very difficult to protect
at this point.
And we do have
protections in place.
We have secure boot mechanisms,
and the TPMs that make sure
that the hard drive
and the machine
hasn't been tampered with.
But it's much harder to
protect at that layer.
So that's why physical
security is so important.
And then to your second
question, is like--
are people trying to break
into Google data centers?
I mean, we can't go
into a ton of detail,
but the answer is not no.
And the answer is
not unique to Google.
Right?
We know that customers
store data in data centers.
Even what we call colo
data centers, which
are data centers
as a service, much
smaller than a public
cloud provider--
they have the same
levels of security,
or similar levels of security,
because this data is important.
Customers are trusting
Google to secure their data.
If we do have a data
breach, it erodes the trust
that customers have in
securing their data with us.
So this is why
it's so important.
And just yesterday,
and the day before,
and the day before that--
in the past three days,
there have been three
major independent security
breaches targeting companies
that are of the size of Google.
So it's really not
out of the question
that people are trying to gain
access to these data centers,
and that's why we have
these protections in place.
STEPHANIE WONG: All right.
Well, here is another
question that we have received
from many of our viewers--
what if a data center
catches on fire?
Would everybody in the
world lose their data?
So this is one of my favorite
questions that we get.
So Carter, can you help
us out with this one?
CARTER MORGAN: I'm going
to play with that question
a little bit.
If a data center caught
on fire, would the world
lose all of its data?
No, because not all the
data in the whole world
is stored in one data center.
STEPHANIE WONG: But what
about aliens or zombies?
CARTER MORGAN: OK.
So this is--
SETH VARGO: What
about zombie aliens?
CARTER MORGAN: All bets
are off at that point.
I'm hiding in a data
center if that happens.
Look, here's the thing we've got
to watch for, or think about.
When it comes to this,
every organization,
if you store important
information-- whether it's
in a file in your
desk somewhere,
whether it's on a computer,
whether it's in a data center--
you have to have a plan
for the unfathomable,
for disasters, for having
to recover your data
for a national disaster.
STEPHANIE WONG: OK,
well, what about a spy
or national disasters
like floods?
CARTER MORGAN: Yes, you have
to have a plan for as much
as you possibly can.
I don't think you can
plan for everything,
but data recovery is
one of those things,
and redundancy is
one of those things.
So you know that there's a--
SETH VARGO: What about Godzilla?
CARTER MORGAN: All
right, I'm about to quit.
[LAUGHTER]
There's a lot that
could happen, and I'm
sure everyone here
could go into more.
But one of the things that
Google does really well
is they duplicate data
when necessary, they
have multiple zones,
they have regions.
So someone like a
customer can say, hey,
I want to make sure that my
data is replicated across zones
so that if a zone
goes down I can
have data still up and online.
And so that's one of
the things that you
have to do when you're
securing your own information,
is set up a disaster
or data recovery plan.
And Google has some
of this in place,
too, at the data center
level to help protect you.
But like Seth and
Stephanie were saying,
there are so many
different cases.
Do you guys have
a little bit more
about how to actually set
this up, or how much of it
is Google's responsibility
versus how much is
the customers' responsibility?
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
And something that we
already talked about
is that the SOC, the security
operation center of all Google
data centers, are also
designed to roll up
to a regional SOC
for multi-regional
high-availability purposes.
So if an on-site SOC
were to be disrupted
due to an event such
as a natural disaster
or an emergency
building evacuation,
then monitoring
instantly rolls over
to the regional SOC for
continuous, uninterrupted
monitoring.
So SOCs act as a center for
emergency and safety response
in addition to security
responsibilities,
like Seth mentioned earlier.
These SOCs monitor
and respond to alarms
at all of our facilities,
and are constantly
tracking local and global events
that could impact operations
at our data centers.
So really, you can think of
this like high availability
for physical security, and that
means it's high availability
for logical security and
data protection as well.
And then one thing
that is cool to mention
is that we do run
dozens of drills a year,
paying unannounced
skilled adversaries to try
to get past controls
by any means necessary,
except for violence.
And this includes
everything from fake badges
to social engineering, fake
UPS trucks, ladder trucks
to get over the fence, people
actually hidden in trucks,
or attempts in different
environments, like thick fog.
And we usually win.
After every attempt,
the main thing
is that we want to run
a blameless post-mortem
to improve and make the
next attempt even harder.
And we ensure the strength
of our security controls,
and then we iterate
controls as needed.
So this is all about building
a culture of security.
SETH VARGO: Yeah.
And we also have an
exercise at Google
which we call DRT, disaster
and recovery testing, which
affects both the software
security side and the data
center security side, where--
to directly answer
this question,
what happens if there's
a fire at a data center--
we have in the past completely
severed a connection
to a data center to make sure
that our disaster recovery
protocols were in place.
Because yeah, you can
write something down.
You can put it in a Google Doc.
You can print it out
and put it in a safe.
But an untested backup
plan is not a plan.
So we actually write, and we've
written multiple white papers
about this, where we
actually do some crazy stuff.
Like we'll cut off the entire
Mountain View office and all
of our senior
executives' cell phones,
and make them
inaccessible, and make sure
the organization can continue
to function from a business
continuity perspective.
But we'll also take an entire
data center, quote, "offline,"
by maybe severing
the fiber connection
to make sure that our disaster
recovery plans are in place.
STEPHANIE WONG: All right.
So our final question of the day
comes from Martin W., who asks,
I'd love to work
in a data center,
so I have to ask, how
does one go about getting
a job at a data center?
So we love this question.
Seth, do you have
any tips for Martin?
SETH VARGO: Yeah.
So you can always check out
the Google Careers page.
And I think we'll either
drop a link in the comments
or we'll show it
on the screen here.
But we actually have a lot of
openings at our data centers.
We also have a lot of openings
for software engineering
positions, site reliability
engineering positions.
The only one that
guarantees you'll
see the inside of a data center
is the data center engineering
positions.
But you should always check
out the Google Careers page.
You can filter by location,
including remote work.
And we're always opening up
new positions and new areas.
You can also set up alerts
to get an email any time
a position opens up that fits
your custom filter criteria.
CARTER MORGAN: I so--
sorry, I just so really
want to try and get a job
sneaking into the data centers.
Like, if that's on that
page, I'm signing up today.
SETH VARGO: Those are
usually external firms.
I actually used to work for one.
You won't find that on
my resume or LinkedIn,
but it's a really fun job.
But you will occasionally end up
in jail, at least for a night,
while they get a hold
of the CISO or the CIO
to confirm your
story that you were
in fact hired by
the agency that you
were penetrating at the time.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Yeah, and I'm also
hosting the second season of
"Where the Internet Lives"
podcast.
And that's where we explore more
roles like environment, health
and safety operations,
mechanical engineers, data
center technicians, and
hardware operations managers.
So check that out.
We're going to be diving into
the background of the people
who are employed
at data centers,
and you'll probably learn about
some roles that you don't even
know about yet.
We also are creating this
animated series on our YouTube
channel here-- it's called
"Discovering Data Centers"--
where we explore the innovations
that exist at our data centers
and how we physically
build our data centers,
all the way down to the software
stack that makes our technology
built at the data center so
distributed and at scale.
Lastly, I do want to just
mention that the career site is
going to be included
in the links
here so that you
can check it out.
And we are always hiring for
roles, even internships, all
over the world.
So right now we have
open roles in Singapore,
in Japan, all over the
US, and Chile, so be
sure to check that out.
All right.
Well, that's all the time
that we have for today,
unfortunately.
But thank you so
much for everyone
joining our
#AskGoogleCloud live chat.
We hope that your
questions got answered.
We're going to be back with more
live chats throughout the year.
As a reminder, we'll be
featuring your questions
from YouTube,
Instagram, Twitter,
so send in your questions using
the hashtag #AskGoogleCloud.
And comment below if
you have a question
that we didn't get to today.
So thanks, everyone,
for watching.
We'll see you all next time.
And Seth and Carter,
stay out of trouble.
[LAUGHS]
[MUSIC PLAYING]